And boom. Right when you take a drink of water, that's when we go live.
Always good to see you. Good to see. Thanks for having me Bro. My pleasure.
I'm a big fan.
I've been a fan for a long time and I'm very excited about this Bahari rematch.
So we were just talking about it. That's going to be in December. Yes sir. Yeah,
it's going to be huge is I think is going to be the biggest fight in kickboxing
history. I think it's already,
I mean you were just saying that the tickets go on presale today I think. Yeah,
today or tomorrow. So, um, where is it going to be held? It's in Holland.
It's going to be in Holland. Yeah. It's called the hell the dough.
And how many seats is that?
I believe around 25. 30,000. Wow.
That's crazy. How big kickboxing is in Holland is a para post to America. Yeah,
it's Holland. Europe. It's a lot bigger than it is here.
So we I d I do not for the life of me understand why it hasn't taken off in
America. I don't get it. Well, I think it,
the step of going to MMA than to kickboxing.
It's so much close to people. For example, from high school,
it's so much more logical when you do wrestling, do a little bit of boxing.
Well let's jump into MMA that because it's so close to each other and when you
go to kickbox it's totally different. Right? It's slightly different.
So many people in America when they watch MMA, they want guys to stand up. Yeah,
I know. That's why it doesn't make any sense still.
I think like every country is like very patriotic.
They want their own guys to be very good at something sort of.
But like when Anderson Silva was at the top of the heap in MMA,
everybody wanted to see him fight. Yeah.
It didn't matter that he was from Brazil. Yeah, that's true. In America.
They still wanted to see him fight. He's just,
they want to see high level stuff.
It's just everyone here is such a fan of knockouts and and striking and high
level striking. I just don't understand it. No more tied to you.
My tie doesn't sell at all. No. You mean there's no big Moitai events.
Like they had a pro Moitai league event here and it was in like Nicky hold skin
fought on it and um, bull cow and a,
a few other big name guys. Um, fought on it. But it was like, you know,
nobody in the crowd. No. But Shell is also like Moitai so,
so with the clinching and they hold to it, it's like,
I think it's a little bit boring.
Like w what we do with glory now is it's like more commercial.
You can hold like just for three, three seconds, right.
And then break and then continue fighting. So, and in the end,
that's what people want to see. I get that. But I like clinch work too.
And I like elbows, elbows and knees and the clinch. You don't like it.
I like the knees, but no, too many caught that nasty.
Yeah. Nasty. So cots are nasty. Yeah. So I had,
what do you think about how liked the amateur when we tie guys have elbow pads?
[inaudible] that's,
I think that's probably in all this preventive for people who don't understand
what we're talking about.
It's weird that like we see you could t you could see with bare knuckle boxing,
like there's a lot of bare knuckle boxing matches now and you see these guys
faces are just getting destroyed as, I mean they just ripped apart. It's crazy.
It's not healthy. No it's not.
It's definitely not good for the longevity of your career. No.
And so in Amateur Moitai they have these elbow pads that they wear and that
would mean your still can knock guys out just as easily,
but you're not going to get the cuts. Exactly. Cut to the bed. That's it.
That's a good thing. Yeah. But I'm just not a big fan of a, of the elbow,
the elbow work. But I love to see it, but I like to get it.
Cause I remember, I remember, I remember, uh, I was, I was, I wasn't,
I don't think I was training with the black zillions like years ago.
I think it was even before I, I became champion and I was training,
they're doing a little bit of MMA,
helping some guys out and I was training and somebody could just,
he said on accident, he just pop through loe right on the nose.
He just opened it up just a little bit and ask him, what the hell are you doing?
Yeah, I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Yeah, cause accident. Yeah, that accident.
So we'll give them a few extra low kicks after that. And MMA, I mean,
it's such a staple technique, you know, it's probably hard to not do it.
Even had a couple of them I may fights. Right honey? One, just one. Yeah.
You mounted the guy. That was what was crazy tipped to the ground. I was like,
let's, let's give it a try. When winter we got to try everything.
But when I saw it I was like, damn, if he makes his way to MMA,
because the heavyweight division, particularly in the UFC is extremely shallow,
extremely shallow. I mean you have some great talent,
but there's like four or five really good fighters. You know, it's like,
there's obviously Cormier gay, there's steep pay, Frances and Gano.
There's a few other guys, but it's you, you know, with a couple of wins,
you're in the mix for a heavyweight title shot. Yeah. You know,
have you your thought about doing that?
I thought about it because he's still young. Right? How old are you? 30. Yeah.
See which is crazy because you've had a lot of fights, right? Yeah.
I had about 60, 70 fights. Yeah. That's crazy. You know,
and it's, um, and,
but the thing is as European like fighting and glory, like it's uh,
that's what people don't understand. It is enormous overseas.
It's hard for people to, in America they're like, what kickboxing.
But if you go to see those events, I mean, I watch all of them.
You watched the events on television.
It's like fucking crazy packed crowds and always full.
The first fight you had with barter, Holy Shit. Was that crowd hot?
That was a wild crowd that even like jumped through to the ropes. Everything.
Everything went crazy so well, it ended in a fucked up way.
You know? Botter said his arm was, what was the, did,
did he get an MRI or anything like that? I have no clue.
I'm not from the organization or something. So yeah,
he did some bandage or something over his arm in the neck. He,
because that's what he posted on Instagram. But I don't know. I don't know.
For me it was a, yeah. You know,
it was like a anticlimax that wasn't the way I wanted it to end that fight.
Right. But I think for the rest, for, uh,
for him this was the perfect way to end the fight because this is the way you
could,
you could get a rematch cause he would have lost no point in doing a rematch if
he would get knocked out. No point in doing the rematch. So, well, my siblings,
I'm really close fight and then you eventually one. Yeah. You know,
but from, from my feeling, uh, everybody said yeah, but uh,
Rico walked into the jabs the first round and everything. That's true.
But I was pressuring him.
I was pressuring him the whole time and I was trying to feel like,
where is my distance? Where I can hit and where I can, where I get hit.
So on of course. That's right. You get tagged. Yeah, you get text sometimes.
So my, my nose was already a during training,
my nose opened up so when he hit it, it opened up again. So I was like, yeah,
it is what it is, you know, like I'm not really bothered by it.
So I went suppression impression and I was like, okay, now I've got,
now I got it.
So after that first round and then we jumped into the second round and I was
fit, I was ready for it. I was ready for this fight.
And that's what I like to do. I would like to drag people into the deep waters.
Well, you're very fit for a heavyweight. You have crazy cardio.
That's one of the things that I've always admired about your fighting styles.
So you put insane pressure on guys for heavyweight because heavyweights,
bigger guys tend to fight at a slower pace and less volume. But you,
you push a pace and when the fight gets to third, fourth, and fifth rounds,
you fucking pilot on man. Yeah.
Because I've been training with a light guys for like my whole career.
So when I started the gym, I started that with the Super Pro sports center. Uh,
with Dennis Kerrville. He had, uh, Albert Kraus,
he was the first k one Max champion and he had Elvir Lima,
like multiple, a middleweight champion world champion.
So I was working with those guys like every day and they just kept on pressuring
me and like Blah, blah blah blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
I was getting my ass whooped like almost every day by like guys every way,
like 75 kilos. So I was like,
I can keep hitting him to keep hitting those guys hard or just go with less
power and pressure them.
Like they tried to pressure me and of course in the beginning is like still you
get tired, but at a certain moment you get like, hey,
this is going better and we're just nothing to hit them. Yeah.
Don't try to hit them hard,
but just try to keep the work pop up like a machine gun.
Is that something that happens in a fight as well?
Where you have to balance out how hard you swing versus like a,
not going full blast,
but going technical or knowing that you can start on loading in the third,
fourth and fifth rounds,
see them fade. But it's, for me it's like I'm playing a game.
For me this is,
we always say fighting is a thinking man's game because fighting,
everybody can fight when they have to. Everybody can fight.
When doesn't matter what person.
When you put them in a corner and it's life or death, everybody can fight.
But it's, it's so much more than that.
It's so much more than just fighting. So in that dry, how I try to, uh,
step into the ring with that mentality, like
don't understand that who've never competed the managing of the resources is a
big factor. Right?
Like when do you decide to hit the gas and you see like guys in MMA see it with
a guy like Nick Diaz. Like Nick Diaz is famous for not hitting guys hard.
He just stays on you. Yeah, he just stays on.
You had a lot of volume and then you get tired and then he starts unloading.
Exactly know with big shots.
So, and that's, that's what I like to do. Um,
the biggest compliment I could get from an opponent, and I had it like from my,
like my last six opponent, I got like three or four times this and like Rico,
now I understand why you are the champion.
I fought everybody but this I have never felt before and you're on a different
level. And that's the biggest compliment I could get because I'm in the,
in the ring for five rounds with this guy and they,
they got every opportunity to do everything they've trained for with me for five
rounds. So I didn't knock them out. We just fought for five rounds,
but they just did not know what to do. And that's, yeah. For me,
the biggest compliment I could get.
Yeah. To be technical and to just play your game. Exactly. Yeah.
I really loved your rematch with Jamal.
Ben Sadeek was one of my favorite fights.
I believe that it was a great fight that was like the full rocky version of a
fight that people would love to see.
You get tagged in the beginning and then you
overwhelmed him and then when you put him away I was like, Holy Shit.
What a fight. What a fight that was. That guys a big mother fucker too. Yeah.
Yeah,
there's a big guy and uh,
that I lost against in late back in the days and when I was like,
just a little little kid and so this fight brought something with it as well.
He's like, yeah, he's the champion now, but I beat him, but it was like six,
seven years ago. I'm a totally different fighter than I was back then.
Says let's go. I'm ready for you. So yeah, this was the, the,
the best thing I need. He spit in my face during a press conference.
So I got some extra motivation for that. Well,
you played it out
perfectly to where even when he hit you and hurt you early in the fight,
you stayed calm, you didn't get emotional, you use good defense.
And then once you got him into the deep water,
you stopped him in the fourth and the fifth. Fifth round. Yeah.
Once you got him into deep water, then you piled it on and then put them away.
Yeah. But then again, it's the same thing for me. Everybody. I said,
how did you do that? You got tagged? And I said, but then again,
like I said, it's a thinking man's game, right?
I get hit from my point of view, I made a mistake.
I switched to South Pole,
but instead of switching and stepping outside of his front leg,
I was right in front of his, uh,
of his leg and he was just throwing a left, a left. Right.
And I was walked straight into that. And that's w that's what happened.
It's not that from my point of view that he timed death.
So it happened. And from that moment I can do two things. I can think,
okay,
I can jump into the fight and try to get that point or whatever that moment back
or just thinking my mind like, okay, fuck it.
You lost this round.
Take it and let's go fresh into the second. That's what I did.
So just think about, okay, I lost this round,
but I've got four more to go and I got back into the corner and Motrin says,
Hey, you back. So Yep. Okay. He's tired now.
Yeah. When he tried to unload on you,
he emptied out a lot of the gas tank when you had your hurt.
Yeah. Yeah. So
right. Trying to figure out when you can finish and when you [inaudible].
Exactly. Yeah. Just stay focused.
They relaxed and of course he hit me with someone with some good shots, but,
well, he's a big powerful guy. Yeah. He's always a dangerous fighter that,
that guy's huge. What is he like six, nine, six 10 or something like that? Yeah.
Yeah. And then, yeah,
it's huge in like 270 pounds, I think.
Yeah, that's, that's a mother fucker. That's a big motherfucker.
So [inaudible] he's like, yeah, now it's one, one. I said, come on man,
you beat me like six, seven years. [inaudible] yeah, he was.
He had since then, I don't know. He won a tournament last year.
So he'll selling a few. Yeah. So maybe that fight is going to come.
But like I said, now I'm in, uh, like last year,
the 31st of December, my contract was finished with glory.
So we've been in negotiations ever since. So from that moment on,
I said in my last contract,
you guys told me that about our fight was going to happen and it didn't happen.
So that's when I won first gave me the butter fight.
And from that moment on we going to discuss. Yeah.
So Pete does what we're doing.
Ford bought her. Hari is one of the biggest names in the sport. Like forever.
He's, he's a guy who he's stopped Alistair Overeem.
He, you know, he's fought k one thought
everybody some issue [inaudible] arts mean he, he's a fucking wild man too.
Yeah. You know, but he hasn't fought in high level competition for a long time.
And then he fought you. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So the thing was everybody was, uh, I was beating everybody.
I was champion and I was beating everybody. People said, yeah, we cause good.
He's the champion. But he hasn't fought, bought her. I was like, Hey,
if he was so unnatural, [inaudible] just said, hey, if he wants to fight,
let's go. But he had been dealing with a bunch of legal trouble.
He had a lot of problems. Yeah. He broke someone's leg in a club. Yeah. A lot.
A lot of shit. Crazy shit.
There's a video of him slapping some guy's face at a hotel.
Imagine that guy slapping your face, your support,
you working behind the counter. Bonner comes in and like you
do everyone here take their Kieser,
which really just tell us yours. Yeah, so, so yeah, he had a bunch of problems,
but then the,
eventually the fight happened because that's the fight that people wanted to
see.
But for me it was just like another fight and then the fight at the end,
the fight ended that way. Yeah, that was too bad. So,
but now we can do it again. Yeah. So the fight was quite awhile ago.
How long ago was that? 2016 yeah,
that's why did it take so long for the rematch of dead?
There was a bunch of stuff going on in between.
And like last year he fought has the Girgis also a good kickbox I believe he's
now doing MMA in Bella tour and he's fought before,
right? Yeah, he fought as before but got disqualified. So that's right.
He stomped him with his stuff around. Yeah. So, so, but after that,
that's so crazy. And then two wild dude. Yeah.
And then after that fight they both got, uh, got uh,
caught with using whatever. Oh, steroids. Yeah. Oh, so,
so they, they both got suspended and I believe Hesty has,
he wasn't suspended, I don't know. But he got suspended til December this year.
So that's why.
How did the fight go the last when he fought last year with a head z? Uh,
he won one wasn't easy, but he one was the last,
I mean a a decision or was it decision? Yeah. Yeah.
So for him that was the first fight since your fight with him in 2016.
Is that it? Yeah, cause he's been,
cause he's had on and off. Yeah. But, um,
and then now he's not training at Mike's gym anymore? No, no, no, no.
Do you know who he's training with? Uh, I don't remember his name,
but I know I know the guy, but don't always training with,
well he looks good on Instagram for sure. It looks very fat. A lot of people,
a lot of people look good on Instagram. You know that you see me real life,
it looked totally different. Well I'm sure he looks the same, but it's, it's uh,
what's interesting is when your in high level competition, like
he was of course in, you know,
the days when he fought Alster before Alster made the transition full time to
MMA. Um, when he, before he came to Strikeforce and all that stuff. That's,
that's a long time ago. Yeah. You know,
it's probably hard to get back in. I mean,
and to jump straight into top level competition like headsy or especially like
fighting you as a champion. That's a big leap. Right? Yeah.
So, but that's the thing now we both have, so he fought last year,
March and I fought last year, September.
So because I'm was in negotiated and still am in negotiations with glory for new
contract. So it's a, it's both been a while for us,
but I've been before that, I was like in my crazy,
crazy active flow.
Yeah, you definitely have much more momentum and just,
there's a thing about fighting too, when guys take a long time off,
it's almost like they, they lose the feel for it. Yeah. They lose,
you know how obviously they know how to kick, they know how to punch,
they know what to do. They're in shape,
but there's a field that they have for the ring.
Exactly. Exactly. This, that this is where people don't. And I said like, Hey,
you stepped into the ring and that's what, that's what you do.
This is what you were born to do. That's true.
But you need that attention.
You need to have five of walking towards the ring, stepping into the ring.
All those people looking at you at that moment.
That's a certain type of feeling that you get and you gotta be comfortable with
it. Yeah. And that, that's exactly what it is.
You gotta feel comfortable and the only way you can be comfortable and stay
comfortable is being active.
Yes. Being active. It's very, it's, it's just so critical for a fighter when,
when a guy takes a year off or two years off, or three, I mean it's like oof.
The more the time is, the more it becomes problematic. Yeah. Yeah.
And the older you get [inaudible] how old is bother now? 35 I think.
[inaudible] so yeah, just glory drug test. Yeah, they do.
That's how they got caught. Was it him or was it an athletic commission? I mean,
was it Gloria or was it a no, it's not glory. It's an induction.
Local look at Dutch athletic club and so they're going to drug test for this
fight as well. Yeah, yeah, yeah, for sure. So I got tested like every,
every time. Is it like why the testing?
Like the same standards like world [inaudible]. Yeah.
So they like wake you up like seven o'clock in the morning. Hey Rico. Oh No, no,
no, no. That's not the testing we did. Just, that's at the events.
I would even rather have that you just wake up and random come to us.
But that's not what they, they do that. But that,
that's like really strict when you, when you're there. Yeah, that's,
that's a little bit easier to pass though. That's true.
That's a lot easier to pass I should say. I have no clue.
I don't know what to do or what ways that are too,
because I'm not on it. I don't want to stay busy.
I don't want to think about it. Right. But whatever, you know,
I just jump in there, just do what I gotta do.
But that's why I told glory now and again after this whole issue,
because a lot of people were caught like last year and they didn't expect that.
I was like, hey,
we gotta keep doing this because this is the way we make the sports clean.
And I think that's what we deserve because we, yeah, we are,
we are a good sport. We are all athletes, but I want to be safe in the ring.
And what do you mean with safe? You're going into a fight. I understand.
But somebody that uses whatever can maybe just punch a little bit harder in the
beginning of the fight or whatever. I have a little more endurance. Exactly.
You with some punches they wouldn't be able to hit you with than on some shit.
Exactly. So that's what I mean, uh,
with telling Gloria I want to be safe when I'm in the ring. Well, for sure.
I mean if, if one person's on it and one person's not, that's, you know,
it's a, it's a giant advantage and anybody says it's not,
it's just lying to themselves. Yeah. Yeah. So, but um, in the end, you know,
I just go in there and I'm not even thinking about it,
but it is the fight to make and kickboxing too.
And if there's a fight that I could tell people, hey, you gotta watch you,
you really want to know what kickboxing all about. Watch this, fight this,
that is the fight. Because bots are such a wild man.
He's such a knockout artist and you obviously one of the most successful
heavyweights ever. You know, I mean your a,
your kickboxing record and glory and just the highlight reels. Amazing.
You've got so many great fights over there. Yeah.
Been doing so good and really enjoying myself. And that's what I said.
I want to bring kickboxing to a new level.
Like especially when you go now in Holland,
like normally in Holland was like soccer or whatever,
cycling or ice skating.
That's where parents were bring their kids through and do that,
do Kayvon kickboxing and now they're like, hey kick buck. This is cool.
When we got chosen I think like two, three years ago,
what made the change? I think uh,
because of the bother fight that was so we were getting,
we were getting more airtime and after the bonafide and everything that happened
around him and there was surrounding him,
like w w the thing that you said would happen outside in the club and this and
that. He was like
the National Asshole Ryan and I was like the national good guy cause everybody
so and that was like the perfect clash. And then of course,
yeah I beat him. So everybody was like, Oh shit, these are heroes.
Right. So that, that's actually, that's how everything a little bit exploded.
But, um, but again, for you that's unsatisfying the way it happened.
All that he gets his arm injured. Yeah.
In whatever way reason or whatever he thinks happened.
But like you cause you're suspicious about suspicious about it.
So because he's looking at one arm, then looking at the other arm and it just,
it's a vague thing for me, but it's like,
but that's what I have with whole thing that he tries to create.
It's like when he's getting announced and everything, he's like, yeah,
Butter Hari 110 something fights and 90 knockouts.
But I'm obsessed with what I'm doing. Um, uh, when I'm,
when I fight and when I have an opponent and I'm fighting,
I'm looking for everything.
I want to know everything about you and everything these days you can find on
the Internet. So when I'm looking on the Internet for example,
you look at Wikipedia and he looking all, all the fights from back in the days,
k one days. And even before that you maybe get to 60 70 fights.
So where are the other fights?
Does that mean like when you were younger in the youth period,
you did like 40 something fights and they do knock everybody up.
I Dunno,
my train has been there for years even before that and he doesn't know about it.
So that's strange because everything is documented and on the Internet,
everything you can find on the Internet. So, so thing is records inflated?
I think so. He's got some crazy knockout stuff. He got it. Yeah,
the Stefan Leko [inaudible] experience. But that's what I said he got,
he, he, he's got that, he's got amazing records. But yeah,
I think it's not as crazy as they make it to be,
which is crazy because the, the reality is pretty crazy. I mean,
you don't need to hype it up anymore than it really is, right.
Nobody's been there for years. Like, Hey,
you did 100 something fights or so many knockouts. But when I look at it,
if I can't find it because, but maybe it's there, maybe it's that,
maybe it's from years ago or whatever. I don't know,
but that's all that I'm looking at. You're suspicious.
I'm suspicious about it because when I look at Wikipedia and I'm looking at when
he was around, it starts from when he was around 16 till now it's like 60,
70 fights. It's funny when you look at them in the early days too.
He was so skinny. Yeah. Like even when he fought stuff, I'm like, oh yeah.
And then now he's fucking jacked. Yeah.
But he puts so much time into a strength,
strength and conditioning workouts you could see like he's always doing some
crazy strength routine. Yeah. Yeah.
So do you do a lot of strength and conditioning? Like what, what are,
what are your workouts like as opposed to like how much skill work do you do and
how much strength and conditioning work? Uh,
I think it's pretty even balanced out. I think, uh,
I train strength like three times a week,
but even my strength and thing is so balanced out with doing,
strengthening the same, uh, muscle group. I also do conditioning.
So first I do low reps and then I do a lot of reps because these muscles are for
me, aren't supposed to be big. They need to be strong and they can be,
they need to be making the same punch 50 times with the same strength,
right. 10 Times really hard, no 50 times on the same strengths, the same level.
So that's how we approached that. And then yeah, uh,
we got skilled training like two, three times a week. Uh,
like pad work. Uh,
I got explosive training so I try to always look also at different sports at
soccer and American football and at ice skating and they all have a certain type
of explosiveness that they train in a certain way.
So I tried to pick everything from everywhere and work with that.
So we created a training that we just use for explosive,
for being explosive.
So it has nothing to do with endurance because it's maybe like 45 minutes and
he's just few sex. You go, going back, go,
you come back because logically for a big guy, you're slow.
When something is big and heavy, it's slow. And that's where we try to do,
we tried to be as fast as possible for a big guy. So a lot of [inaudible]
plyometric type stuff. Yeah. Explosive type stuff. Yeah. Yeah.
Wade letters and stuff like that. Okay. Yeah. So when you do this kind of stuff,
when you were saying that you lift low reps and then high reps,
so you'd do like heavy weights first to try to like Max out or get the,
the muscles very tired and then really where I'm out with with Reps.
So we do have but we never go Max Max, so. Right, right, right.
Then that like over Max what we,
so you don't deal go to failure with like heavy heavyweights. Yeah.
What kind of stuff are you doing? Are you doing like dumbbells, kettlebells,
a lot of a lot of numbers. Yeah. As minor,
as much loose weight as possible,
like a few a with the barbel but as much with the,
with the dumbbells because that's when you got to keep him balanced and work on
the core and stuff like that.
So what about a sparring home? How often do you spar week?
Uh, normally like twice to three times a week.
And when you do, what are you doing? Hard spot. I know you're from Holland,
those fucking Holland guys like the spar hard man.
Do you do a lot of hearts sparrings that more technical? Like how do you,
how do you balance it out?
Um, it depends, depends on who's who's in.
Because now in preparation we're going to fly guys in and then yeah,
it's going to be pretty tough sparring. Cause that's what you, yeah,
what you got, what'd you get the guys for? Right.
But in the end I'm always thinking about, hey, we do heart sparring,
but we don't want to injure each other. Right.
There's no point for me in knocking guys out Jewing sparring because then I
don't have any supplier partners anymore. Right. So I do hard sparring,
kicked him hard on the legs, kick them hard on the body.
And of course people get knocked, knocked down, not knocked out, but,
right.
But you don't go full blast of the head. No, that's a Holland thing, right?
I mean there's a lot of [inaudible]
you guys do it. Yeah. Like that. But yeah, we'd go, we go pretty tough.
We go pretty tough to the, to the head, black eyes, bloody nose.
But I'm always like 90% [inaudible] I'm always looking at like,
hey, or when I'm making a move and I can make a head kick.
I always try to, when I see I'm going to make a full hit,
tries to keep it back just a little bit. So I think yeah,
but just being controlled, I think it's very important.
So I train with all the guys,
all the heavyweight guys from glory I trained with with,
and of course you do hard sparring, but we do not add,
from my point of view, I don't don't want to injured them. Right. Yeah.
I mean it only makes sense. I mean that's one of the most valuable things,
right? It's to have high level training partners. Exactly.
And if you guys think you're going to put them to sleep all the time,
they're not really interested in spa. For example,
I train with Benny Attic buoy is like the number two or number three in glory.
And I fought him twice, but we train together.
He's now at my gym and I try to make him better say, hey,
try this, try that. And because of his better, your better. Exactly.
And people are like, no, no, no,
I don't want to train with competition because then they know what I'm going to
do. That's true. But you also know what they're doing.
So it just depends on how you approach things.
Every negative thing has a positive thing, edit as well. So that's,
I really always,
I'm always looking at the positive things and always try to surround myself with
people that are positive. And yeah, that's,
that's the vibe that I'm going with because that's what works well.
That's also the mark of a confident fighter. Like you know that you're the best,
so if you help him,
he's just going to help you become even better than you are currently. Yeah.
But you gotta be,
you gotta be comfortable with that because you also see a lot of guys that like,
no, I'm not gonna do that. I'm not going to do this.
I'm not going to help the guy,
not going to tell him whatever because this is not going to be good for me.
But in the end,
everybody that gets better can help me get better as well.
So I always position myself as, as a sponge,
I tried to get this much info in, in wherever I am.
So for example, I'm now really going into acting. I want to, I want to act.
So now Kevin was on your show as well. Kevin Hart. Yeah.
So you're training with them. Yeah. So it was a lot of fun.
The first kick he ever threw, he threw with you. Yeah. So what was crazy?
He's a great guy. He is such a good guy,
but so s so much positivity and he has such a great five and he's such a great
mentor. And I was just sitting there, we were talking and like I said,
I was just positioning myself as a sponge.
I was just trying to get as much information in there as possible. And Yeah,
now I've been, I'm here now in La for about a month now.
I've been training with, with Mark Walberg and also the same thing,
just Anthony hard donk.
Donk is here. It's amazing because when you're in La,
you want to do Dutch kickboxing. That's the place where you got to go. Yeah.
Hard docs. Awesome. I love that guy. Yeah, he's amazing. So, uh,
so every time I went in my lane, I'm going to tell people where to go. Dynamics,
dynamics, dynamics [inaudible], which is in Santa Monica.
And he just said they're opening up another one that he's going to run in west
La. But he's, he's just, he was, when he used to fight in the UFC,
I used to love watching him fight because he was probably one of the best leg
kickers ever in the heavyweight division. He would just fuck guys legs up,
you know. So technical. Yeah. So, so much fun. So last Saturday we, uh,
we started sparring a little bits. He said, yeah,
I'm looking for a little bit of sparring. I said, okay. I said,
he said I didn't do anything for 10 years, but I want to do it.
Just want to help you out. It is good. But I just wanna move around, you know,
I don't, don't want to kick nobody's ass. I just want to move around.
So that's what we did. We had a lot of fun. So, and then you still see,
has that feeling, has that duct kickboxing touch? So it's, it's amazing. Yeah.
No, there's not a lot of like real high level Dutch kickbox and you can get in
California, especially out here. No, no, no.
And he's definitely the guy and girl, but just heavy weights. It's difficult.
Heavyweights barring is hard. Yeah. Good luck. Lively weight sparring.
So yeah, we just keep,
keep going around and that's why I love being here. So actually have,
I'm here for vacation, but when I'm here I gotta work as well. So, right.
So the fight is in December, you were saying it's going to be in when?
December the 21st uh, okay. So right before Christmas. My Christmas. Yeah.
So that's what I said. Yeah. Maybe we'll do it in January as fuck.
I wish it was [inaudible] I wish it was in America.
I would love to see that shit. Well, I don't want to go to Holland. Physi
[inaudible] I didn't want to go to the islands and they don't love Holland.
You let it go busy. You got to come to Harlem and that's a lot of fun. I'm sure.
I'm sure it's a bit, but if it was in like Chicago or some shit,
I'd fly out Holland. That's a fucking, that's a long, that's a lot of flying.
Yeah. It's like time, 11 hours, 11 hours on a plan.
[inaudible] stay for couple of days. I don't have a week to spare. No. I wish
that you busy, man. So you're out here trying to act too.
That's where you going to try to do getting an agent and meeting with people and
stuff like that. Yeah, yeah, exactly. So, um, I'm uh, with, with paradigm,
it's mine, uh, my American management now you taking,
you obviously speak fluent English. Yeah.
But are you taking lessons to get better at it so you can act and all that jazz?
So that's your next goal. Exactly. So, um,
I'm still an active athlete,
but I'm still looking at like, hey,
what can I do next because I can't and I don't want to do this for like 10 more
years. When do you want to retire? Do you have a thought in your head?
I don't know. It depends on where are right now. You're in your prime. Yeah.
So it depends on what comes on my, my roots.
So I still looking at, so now I'm in negotiations with Laurie.
How is Gloria doing as an organization? Are they doing well yet? A noon.
Cause I know they were,
they were struggling a little bit in America and they were trying to dep,
but do they still have events here in America? Yeah, less but less.
Less than in the beginning because Europe is so much more successful.
So dare we fill up like arenas or here we can get like five.
But I went to the last man standing in La when, uh, Joe Schilling was there.
Holy Shit. Was that crazy? Yeah, that was awesome.
But I always tell people like you want to see real high level striking,
you see high level striking in MMA.
But with MMA there's all the other variables. Just take downs and small gloves,
the whole deal. Like to really want to see high level kickboxing. Yeah,
glory is where it's at. Exactly.
So that's for me now where I'm at is like I'm still in negotiation with Gloria
for new contracts and if we,
in what way or the other we can get out of it.
So maybe I'm going to do something else or I don't know. I'm,
I'm looking at the sport like a totally different way. I don't want to,
I think the sport can totally be elevated in,
in all certain ways, you know, all different ways.
Because how crazy would it be to do mixed fights?
It's fun to go from one guy, go to the other sport,
but how cool would it be that the other guy would go to the other sport as well?
So someone
from MMA coming to kickboxing and the other way around. Yeah.
Well the other way around Sikh,
I mean I I could see like Francis in Ghana, no,
I think he would do really well in kickbox cause he's such a fucking
ridiculously powerful striker. Yeah, he would do really well,
but I don't think there's a lot of other, well,
I mean obviously Alster if Allister really dedicated himself to it,
but he's chasing the goal of being the UFC heavyweight champion. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean who else?
I mean the only other organization is one and one has,
uh, they their do kickboxing as well.
Now they do kickboxing and Muay Thai and they do Moitai tie with little gloves,
which is kind of crazy. And that was pretty crazy.
Have you thought about doing that? No, not really.
The gloves, that's crazy. Yeah. But I don't,
I don't mind when doing the small goals, but kickboxing is small gloves.
It's pretty insane. How could the intense,
because there's no way to block anything anymore.
Right. Stand up and fight again.
Just put the gloves out and just do bare knuckle fight because it was almost the
same. So, in
terms of like for people don't understand when you have big gloves on there's
more you can protect yourself. Exactly.
You can shell up better and defensively. You Know Liam? Liam Harrison. Yeah.
He fought in one with little gloves and boy tiny. He was like holy fuck.
He sent me a masters like fucking brutal man. Like he's like,
I can't believe how hard it is. It's so much different. Yeah,
it's totally different. Yeah. She can do whatever.
So yeah, that's, that's pretty insane. So I would like to say,
I don't know why I was doing that. I mean,
cause I know they do have some matches where they wear big gloves just to,
to push the limit of, yeah,
well they have so many different kinds of matches over there.
They even have grappling matches like straight, straight grappling. Yeah.
I don't know that. Well, have you been to one at all? You bet they're gigantic.
Yeah. Yeah. In Asia. Fucking huge man. There's no,
but I've punched friends have gone over there to coach and even to fight.
And you know, in a couple of people from the UFC, Meesha Tate, she's some,
she has some executive position over there right now,
which rich Franklin does as well. We used to be in the middle weight champion,
you're saying? Yeah. So they, they, um,
they have a bigger audience worldwide than the UFC does there humans in Asia
check just gigantic and it keeps getting bigger and bigger.
And they got really high level fighters too. So it's really interesting.
But I know they're doing a lot of kickboxing as well.
Yeah. So who knows? Who knows more than better. Right.
More competition in the battle. Yeah, exactly. Exactly.
Because that's what brings the whole sport up to another level. So that's,
that's, that's perfect. And that's cool. But it's like I said, it's,
I just like to do different stuff and now, like I said, I don't want to do,
I don't want to fight for another 10 years, so let's see. What would, yeah,
what's going to happen, you know, I'm gonna make a movie either way.
So I'm going to start filming a movie in the beginning of next year.
So that's a, that's pretty cool. It's the movie. Um, it's going to be,
it's like totally, uh, from blank. We started it. So it's been,
it's been written now. I got the first draft of the script and it's, it's crazy.
He's telling me what you do. Uh, yeah. So I'm like a,
like a black ops kind of guy. Uh,
but something happens. You're an operation.
I stopped cause I think this is what happened. It's crazy.
I told them not to do this and it still,
this happened so I'm going to stop and yeah, and then they bring you back.
They, I, I got back, I said that case exactly. Exact people kick them. So, uh,
people of course like of course, but I'm not that,
that's the thing I said I don't want to be a fighter because people already know
me from fighting. So I want to do something else. I want to really show my,
my acting skills. So there's going to be,
there's going to be so much fun and that's what I get my excitement from.
Cause I love doing new songs, doing kickboxing.
So I was six years old and then this like forever.
So I want to do something else as well so that this is going to be a lot of fun.
It's a harder
transition. The not a lot of people have been successful at it.
Like Randy couture is probably the most successful yet. You know, he's,
he's got a real career as an actor now. He acts a bunch of movies, man.
He said obviously he's in the expendables and, but he's always worked.
Yeah. But a lot of in the end when you look at the history,
a lot of athletes did it. Yeah, sure. Not a lot were like really good.
But then again we got like on the watch a n****r Xango for damn sure.
Sure. It's possible. And I like the challenge. Is there,
uh,
ever a worry of being like one foot in one foot out with your fighting career?
Like acting starts to take off, but you're still fighting?
Is there a worry about not being 100% all in? No. No.
Because then the thing we said,
I also discussed this with my trainer cause he's really crushes with that.
He's like, Hey, when we focus on making a movie,
that's what we are going to feel gonna focus on and if you're going to have a
fight, we're going to fully focus on that.
So those side things or let's do this for a second and then we go back and I'm
just going to focus on that because that's what does fighters in exactly.
I mean you've seen it like that.
That happened with Ronda Rousey's happened with other fighters where they just
get too spread thin,
they get spread too thin and they have too many different projects can work
simultaneously. I still date people still say that about me now at this moment.
Like Rico's not focused, he doesn't say hey, but I trained every day.
I'm focused in what I'm doing. I'm focused and kickboxing,
but I just like the acting part and I just want to gain my knowledge and
get better at it. So you got to train it the same escape boxing.
Yeah. It's just gotta stay focused. Do you, do you ever do any Jujitsu? Uh,
I did some, yeah, I did some. Yeah, I like it. I like it. It's a lot of fun.
But now the last two years had been so busy, uh,
with kickboxing and everything that happens on the side and just no time.
So you don't have any real designs of eventually transferring to MMA?
You know, like I said, for me, um, when I look at it, it was,
people ask me, ask me this a lot, like, Rico would you,
why don't you go to MMA? Yeah, yeah. It could be, it could be possible,
but like from, if I look at it, honestly,
it's not my basic, uh,
ambition to go there because my ambition, my next ambition,
cause when I look at it, it's like if you jump into something different,
you should have the will and want to be the best and,
and don't necessarily have the will to be the best at MMA,
but if you get a crazy offer,
that's what I was going to say. Someone comes along with the real shackles.
You can buy some stuff. [inaudible] come on. Gotta look.
Okay. Okay. Keep it going just a little bit more. Let's go.
I got this. I'm motivated now so that,
that's exactly what, uh, yeah, but if you decide to do that,
how much time do you think you would legitimately need for like a real high
level opponent to work a year? Take down a year? Yeah. Take down.
Because I know what to do. I've, I've trained this for like two, three years,
so I know, uh,
but my body just needs to work on it. Have them ever fight in between, uh,
maybe another fight and then I'm going to be able to do a high level fight.
Or do you do any other kind of cardio? Do you run or of course, yeah.
Do you hate it? Hate it. But you have to do it. Yeah.
Well it's, it's also for a big guy,
it's more of a pain in the ass to like what do you,
what do you weigh about two 50, somewhere around there.
Uh, two 60, two 60. So that's when you're running. That's a lot of weight.
As a lot of weight on your joints.
Cause of the the pressure and so but in the end,
how much I did this, the,
it works for me because it's also for me a mental training because I hate it so
much and I jump on a treadmill or I go outside and I just want grown [inaudible]
you gotta keep going, you gotta keep going because when you get,
you have that feeling like 90% of the people would stop
but you are not that person. You got to keep going and that's what,
that's what motivates me just to do things different than everybody else.
Does being comfortable being uncomfortable. Yes, exactly. The grind,
the grind is, I think that's the moment when it, when it starts,
when you get that feeling shit is going to hurt,
your body starts hurting and that's when like a lot of people give up and that's
where we as champions, we continue.
It's interesting too because a lot of fighters,
they'll do all sorts of high intensity training and interval training and all
these different plyometrics and cardio and and different things.
But many of them will tell you that one of the more important things is just
long range running because when you do this long distance running where you're
on five, six, seven miles, when you do that,
you develop this cardio base where you can just keep working and you recover
faster. And it's just, I mean this,
one of the things that if you go back and look at old time fighters, you know,
back to Muhammad Ali, sugar ray Robinson, all those guys,
everybody ran rocky Marciano. Everybody ran. Yeah. There wasn't an option.
It wasn't like you don't have to run. We can do a bunch of other things like no,
no fighters run.
Yeah, that's what we do. Yeah, but it's just,
I always feel like running is not,
the m is not the base of your, it's not most important,
but it's like really important factor of the total package. Right?
So it's just your yet the,
the oxygen you have like for keeping the same pace for a longer,
a longer time.
Then of course the explosiveness that we use during a fight is important.
But also just, yeah, the, the,
your basic lung capacity should be, should be big as well.
What about heavy bag work? Yeah, we do it but not that much.
Nothing like once a week. Some more pad work.
More things.
Yeah. Not like, cause I see some guy,
it's really interesting how different camps, different fighters,
different trainers prefer different preparation methods and some swear by
intervals in the heavy, heavy bag. Some swear by doing rounds on the heavy bag,
you know, and some, some don't think it's that critical. Yeah.
I think for everybody's different. Yeah.
But like for me,
throughout all those years I've been trying different stuff and I think now I
created the right combination of different trainings,
just polishing everything.
And I think I found the right way to get fit because I don't need to get,
I need to get better. I always, I'm always looking to get better.
But you get better by putting in the work.
But I'm always looking at how can I change my training up?
What would be an add on what in what I already have? Right?
So now I think I created the right combination but,
and still I'm looking to add stuff on,
but I think I created the right way to get fit for a fight.
Cause I've shown that throughout all those years I've shown that I'm fitter than
all the rest. And that's,
that's a part but a still I think the biggest differences that everybody is
strong and everybody's fit. Everybody can fight.
But the biggest difference is mentally what happens to you mentally when you get
to the fourth and fifth round thing. That's the most important thing.
How strong are you mentally to continue fighting?
A lot of people when you feel like always for the people that do not understand
what this, what this fighting game is,
what happens to you when you're in the ring or in an octagon?
So you can always compare it with driving a car.
You driving a car and the last one is 40 50 miles.
The guests, light comes on, hey, you got to get gas.
That's the same thing that happens to your body when you get tired as science,
whatever happens in your mind or your head, hey, you're tired.
When you're tired, you need to rest.
And we as athletes,
we do not listen to that light that goes off in your car.
And even, yeah,
I call, I don't listen. I always go, I had a few times that was undecided,
the road without gas. So I'm sorry, but she said,
psychological dude do that because you think of your car like a body.
Like you chat to fuck you car. Don't be a pussy. Hey Joe, thank you.
I appreciate that. But yeah, I think that is what it is. You know,
it's like the same game you're playing, play that game to your car.
It's so stupid.
But for me it works because I always push my car to the limit.
That's why I did what I do to myself as well, you know?
And that's what I luckily have a great team, uh, people around me for,
because even when everything is hurting and tired and I almost get over-trained,
my people have to pull me back. Say Rico,
just no point in training now because you're going to get over-trained and
you're going to fuck yourself up. Right? So it's that fine balance, right?
It's hard to figure out. I don't, I have to balance. I don't have it.
I tried to have it and every time in, in preparation,
I think I got it now I got it. I don't got it. No.
So you need other people around you.
The people that objective that can tell you like, Hey Rico,
you gotta you gotta step back. Because for me, in my mind, I dunno what it is,
but we're not, when I'm not working,
I'm standing still or going down. That's what happens in my mind.
So I gotta keep working and gotta keep grinding. Right?
But that's also because of your style,
because of the fact that you do push such a tremendous pace that you're,
you're constantly feel like you have to have your foot on the gas. Yeah. Right.
That's interesting. So you've been with the same coach for a long time? Yeah,
like since I was like 17 oh, so that's great.
So they know you the key when I come in,
so know what's going on. So critical. Right. And that the whole team,
so my power coach. Oh, okay. So the same, same team the entire time.
Can you imagine like, like in the beginning of when we were working,
like when we work in like for three,
four years and then I come in Monday morning power training
and my trainer walks up to me and looking at me, what the hell,
what the hell do you do this weekend? What do you mean?
What have you been eating? Yeah.
Saturday night I went to the McDonald's. What's the problem?
Look at your blown head man. See that like, yeah, you know,
fat old stuff. The water in your, the flu.
He could tell from one McDonald's meal. Really?
That's how close we were.
That's how like he sees me like multiple times a week.
So he saw me like, like Fridays. So he just knows you just,
he just knows everything. Did you monitor your heart rate or anything like that?
Uh, yes. Every morning I, uh, I uh,
checked my blood pressure and stuff like that. Uh, get my temperature. Do,
do it with a computer. Do you have a program? [inaudible] no, no, no.
Just write it down. Just write it down and then, uh, send it to the,
to the doctor every now and then.
So if your heart rate is a little bit too high in the morning,
do you just do it like an active recovery day? Just relax. Yeah, we, uh,
we now check it more through the temperature than through the heart rate.
Really? Yeah. Temperature. Yeah. Interesting. So I,
my temperature is up. I gotta Watch out.
So you might be fighting off a cold or something like that, something like that.
Fighting off a cold or you still a,
your body's still recovering from the last four gallon last trainings.
So from that we can,
so we haven't done it now for a few years and that's exactly when,
when I feel like, hey my, my temperature goes up and it goes there,
this doesn't feel good. And then every time when we,
in the end we always look back at an analyze stuff and then my traits, hey,
exactly there. Cause this training was shit. So you take,
do you use this like do you make a log during your training,
compare it to like your last camp and you look at the numbers and make sure that
everything lines up. Yeah.
So you kind of have to be right at this point in time if you want to really get
everything dialed in and you kind of have to be scientific about everything,
right? Yeah. Because there's so much more than just, uh,
fighting and good training.
It's like good nutrition and this and that and it's just everything has to be
balanced out. I was going to ask you about that.
Do you have a dietician or someone who cooks for you? Uh, yeah. So in, in,
in, in camp. So in, uh, I, I think like two years ago,
I started with that. Do you eat horse meat? No,
it's not a big thing over there.
Like Allister's is a big horse meat guy and I don't think it was a good excuse.
The things that he did next to mixed dividing. That's it.
Everybody said to everybody, I was like, yeah, Hornsby. Yeah. Hey,
it works. Yeah. Look at the size of them. Gotta know what horse?
Yeah. So, no. So that's a no, I,
I've no clue. No Guy, but it's not like in my diet or something.
Just what do you eat a lot? In a lot. Yeah.
Multiple meals a day. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. For sure. So, uh, but that's,
that's the fun people. Like how much do you eat? It's,
it's crazy. It's, yeah, but I burn a lot as well, so I have to,
and for me,
doing the fun thing with that is that the fight industry thing,
when I tell people, said when I get closer to the fight,
I'm eating myself slim. So the more I'm eating,
the slimmer I'm getting because I have training very hard.
And your body's just in a burning process, right.
When the food is gone, it's gonna start burning fat.
So I get slimmer the closer I get to the fight, I said,
but when you see what an aids, like how do you do that?
But it's just all because this is truly training so much. Yeah. So what,
what kind of foods do they prepare for you do they,
did they have like those prepaid pre-prepared packets and you just heat them up
or something like that? Like how does that work? Uh, yeah. Meal,
like a meal prep company does. Yeah, no, it's just like a private cook. Okay.
Yeah. Private [inaudible] runs with me and just make sure every day I get,
and they check the macros and make sure that you get the same,
the right amount of protein, the right amount of carbohydrates.
So there's not like really,
like it's everything is a put it on a scale or something like that.
We don't do that because yeah,
there's certain things I just want a little bit more or I still have,
I'm still a little bit hungry.
So it's not like you need to lose weight or anything. No. So,
but still have in my mind,
always a certain type of fight weight that I like to fight on.
What does that weight like 118 and a half.
118 half kilos. What is that?
I think it's around two to four not two 85 at two 58 I think.
Well, it's 2.2 pounds.
2.2 kilos or 2.2 pounds per kilo when eighteens two 60 pounds to six ounces.
That's right. Right on their home. Yeah. So, okay,
then I'm lying then I'm now a little bit heavier.
Guys. Come on. I'm in La. No, I got it. I went to in and out a few times.
So how could you not,
so it's gotta be around two do 65.
Do you try to stay pretty healthy in terms of your diet though?
Even when you're not in camp? Yeah. Yeah. So for me, because we go,
how do you do it? Is it, for me fighting is a lifestyle. It's not. Um,
it's not like when I go, when I wake up, Oh,
this morning I go to the gym, think about the fight folks, focus, focus,
go out the gym. And my focus is all I said, I wake up with it,
I go to bed with it, and when I'm in bed, I'm dreaming about it.
This is 24, seven. Every day I'm thinking about us. Every meal,
every thing you do is just thinking about what's coming.
That's why you're the champ. Yeah, I think so. I don't think too much,
but for me it's like such a crazy thing that goes on in my mind because I
trained twice a day and then at night when I'm at home, think like,
you know what? I'm in front of television. My wife on the couch, I'm like,
I want to do some stretching and just going to sit on the ground.
Just stretch or do some more app work. It's just, I don't know.
I think like I'm obsessed or of course you have to be obsessed. I mean,
you're in the most, one of the most dangerous combat sports in the world.
And you're the world champion.
So it's constantly that pressure and they're just thinking, Hey,
my opponent probably now is resting or whatever he's doing, I don't care,
but I need to do some next row. So constantly that's that,
that's running through my mind. Everything that I'm doing, he's not doing.
Now do you take vitamins and supplements? What kinds of stuff do you take?
Um, uh, it's really like, uh, like old natural stuff.
And I go through the to the doctor. So, uh,
he takes my blood and then from there on he always looks at how does it look?
This is looking good. Maybe it needs some to wrap a role or whatever. Yeah. So,
uh, so he, uh, he fills it up whenever, uh, whenever it's needed.
And during the period I'm training, I just take the normal,
the normal stuff, magnesium, iron or whatever, vitamin C, stuff like that,
just to keep everything on the right level. And then once a month I go to him,
or the closer we get to the fight, maybe go twice, a twice a month,
and then you just check it like, okay, it's good. Or now, Oh,
you got a lot of white blood cells, so you're getting close to being a,
your muscles are tired, you know,
he getting overtrained to look at that and maybe get some more protein,
you know, and stuff like that. So that's how we try to do that.
What else do you do for recovery?
Do you do any cryotherapy or things along those lines? Yeah,
so I've been stunning dad, like
one and a half year ago or something and it works. I like it to do it. Um,
do you do ice baths or like how do you, what do you do? No,
I just do literally the Cryo [inaudible] the machines all solid.
Frozen. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So I did like, uh, two different, uh, in Holland.
Now it's rec really starting to do, to be hype. So not to get like, uh,
different, uh, places. Uh,
do you go on the one that is from the neck down or the one that gets your whole
body in there? Yeah, so first I started with, uh, with the one with the,
with the neck. Now the whole body is a better one though. Yeah,
this is the place out here. A cryotherapy. It's the fucking shit. I love it.
It's 240 degrees below zero and just go in there for three minutes.
You motherfucker fuck me. I'll get it there.
Like a mental training ass. Come on. You got,
yeah. So, uh, so that's what I started with and then, but deal, uh,
I think the only one we have now is an Amsterdam,
like the full body and like it was like two hours.
Well from the known downs. Good enough. So now I'm gonna I got one,
I got one named my own gym, so I'm just, I can jump in, in and out.
Easy. Yeah.
So just start with that and then from there I'm going to see ya gonna see how it
works, but about sauna. Uh, yeah, I use it, but not,
not too often. So good man. I know. It's so good for recovery. You know,
I, I like it for the full, the first
two minutes and then afterwards I'm like, it's like, again,
it's like metric training. I know, but I'm like, I have to,
my wife's like enjoying it. There's this other stuff like it's so nice
cause you're playing a game with yourself. You can't just enjoy it. Your,
your opponent would probably be get out now. You don't got to stay in, come on.
It's like really sweat, just dripping off. Like it's like really,
I was fucking myself up cause I was trying to crank it up too.
I had layered Hamilton on the podcast. He's a surfer, big time surfer and uh,
his wife, uh,
Gabriela Reese was telling me that he cranks his up to 220 degrees. So, uh,
I did that for a little bit. I got up to like two, 10 to 18,
but it was, I think it was burned in my lungs. I think I was cooking in there.
I really do. I would, I would feel like shit and then I would get out.
I'd be so fucking tired. I was like, I don't think this is good for you.
I dropped down. Now do normal now I do it like one 80, which is normal.
180 degrees Fahrenheit. Oh, that is Celsius.
Yeah. I think like [inaudible]
80, 85. Yeah. But that's normal. That's like a normal hot sauna.
Good enough. 20 minutes I'm in, I'm out. It's pretty hot.
It's pretty hot for me. It's hot man. But it's very good for you.
Those heat shock proteins and they did these studies that showed a 40% decrease
in mortality for all causes, heart attack, stroke, cancer,
40% decrease where people use the sauna for four times a week or more.
That was in, um, what was it? Sweden. Jamie. Do you remember Dr Rhonda? Patrick?
Yeah. She was talking about it. No, that's planning it. Yeah.
It's phenomenal for you because of heat shock proteins.
It makes your body reduces inflammation throughout your whole body as does
cryotherapy. Anything where you're dealing with extreme cold or extreme heat,
your body develops either heat shock proteins or cold shock protein.
Yeah. So I also am, so there was this, this um,
displays where, where I went, where I went for the Cryo and he said, oh,
we also got something else. I don't know what it's called. What is it called?
Can't remember. So you just get like,
like put in a cocoon or something and just go to sleep.
Oh yeah.
You're in water so you're like floating it so the water is like your foot.
Yeah. The void is all floating. It's called floating.
I was like, what the hell? I'm Flo. Definitely the fuck it's called.
You mean like a cry? Like a float tank? Like a [inaudible] here.
It looks like a coon. Oh, okay. I know what you're talking about.
They just close it and they put you in their sensory deprivation tank. Yeah.
For an hour. And you had one right here. Oh really? Yeah. It's awesome.
I'm going to sleep for an hour. It's a big one too.
It's huge. The one I have here is huge. Yeah. Why? Wow. You use a small, yeah,
but that's the best one they have.
I just wanted one that anyone can come in they,
so it's like seven feet long and nine feet high.
Yeah. Yeah. It's amazing. And they said,
they said when you finally get to the point where you know how to
was like mentally relax. It's the same as one.
I was like four or five hours of sleep or something. Yes. Yeah, yeah.
You relaxed and it's also your body absorbed magnesium. Yeah,
because it's Epsom salts, so all the salt that's in the waters,
a thousand pounds of salt in the water, all that Epsom salts,
the magnesium gets through your skin into your bloodstream. So it's really good.
Like it's almost like take new mag weights as good or better take than taking a
magnesium supplement. Yeah. Really good for your muscles too.
Like everything gets loose and relax
and it feels like everything's stretches out and, Yup. What about,
I'm also tried that. Yeah. I'll show you.
I'll show you too when you get out of here. What about a massage?
Do you get massage? Yeah, like daily. Daily? Yeah.
Physiotherapist a comes in to the house and just keeps it,
keeps the blood flowing nice. Just make sure, yeah.
Everything that just full recovery. But also, um,
also just for the injuries, just keep checking like, oh, what's this?
What's that? What's hurting? And so luckily, uh, I've been doing pretty good.
Not Too many injuries. Yeah. Having a good one, a good massage.
Therapists that deal with injuries is just started Ganter. Yeah. Right. Yeah.
It's so important. So they can prevent things, fix things,
things that are starting to go south.
They can stop it in its tracks and make me loosen everything up.
And cause sometimes when you get an injury, right,
everything around it tightens up and then when you're training it gets even more
fucked up. But if someone can loosen that up,
then it has time to relax and feel. Yeah.
Or else it just getting more tense and then you're going to rip something,
something, whatever. So yeah, that's so important.
And I think that's one of the key factors in being a pro athlete.
There's the people you have around you and the team that helps you balance
everything out and they say, hey guys, we go yet you want to fight him? Say,
yeah, I'm Rico to fight.
I'm Rico the champion because of all those people that are the team that are
around me. So still in the end you're doing an individual sport,
but you have a great team around you to be that person that you are in the ring.
And at the highest level, I think you have to have that.
You have to have all the ducks in line, right?
You have to have everything in line if you want to be at the very top of the
heap. Yeah, you have to. What about a psychology? Do you have a,
a mental trainer or anybody who's like a sports psychologist?
Well that's the fun thing. I started off with, um,
the guy I was telling you about, all of your Lima,
he's a also kickboxing wheel champion and different different weight divisions.
And I was training with him and he took me with his training,
took me to his training and I was working with him in his prime and without him
knowing, he was teaching me so much about mental training because
I was training with him and he was never giving up and the moment,
and I just showed something like he gave even extra,
even more gas.
So when you started slowing down and it was even pushing the pace even more.
And that's what I was seeing in his fights and I was just studying him.
And from that I learned so much and I respect him.
I still so much so thankful for that. So, and then he's still my,
my mental coach with that so easily my corner.
And every time when he says something, I just think about,
I don't want to disappoint this man because he knows what,
how important this is. And I think it's from the style last year or something,
I was really like a little bit skeptical about talking to people,
like, like a psychologist or something. I was like, I don't know. Oh,
let's talk about personal stuff, you know?
And it's pretty deep with somebody you don't know is, I don't know,
this maybe in my mind just doesn't add up, you know? Does it feel good?
Uh, but still I got in the situation that had to, or, yeah,
I just, I just had to,
and I went there and it actually felt pretty good.
So from that moment I just kept on doing it. Just talk about,
just talk about stuff I know you like, like no other,
no what,
how many things happened of what everything that happens in your life and you
just gotta process all that stuff. But sometimes she just,
so many things happen in your life that you just can't process and you put them
away and they're fucking with you in the back of your head. Exactly. Exactly.
And then when you just have the time and take the time to talk about this stuff,
you just, it just feels a lot better. It feels like a,
like a bag of bricks on your, on your back. You just fall, fall off.
He's like, yeah, it feels good.
So I think of it the same way you were talking about physical therapy.
They're like, if you have a little injuries,
nagging injuries and get it massaged out and everything loosens up.
I think of at the same way,
if you're not taking a good account of what's going on in your mind,
you can develop like a little mental injuries. Yeah, exactly.
But for me, and maybe a lot of people have, maybe not nowadays,
but like from back in the days,
people still had like when you're talking to her psychology, you crazy know.
Yeah. That's what, that's how people in Holland, like, yeah.
Approached it all for here for a long time here for fighters.
It was the same thing. Like most fighters didn't need a psychologist.
That's not for winners. Winners know how to win. You just don't be a pussy.
Go out there and fucking fight. Yeah. But that's nonsense.
Like there's no pussies in professional fight, you know, you know,
but there is edge, you can get an edge, you can get an advantage.
Whether you get that advantage from getting massage or cryotherapy or from a
sports psychologist, there's advantages to be had. Yeah. So,
but I think that's where my, uh, when I got from my dad, it's just being tough,
being tough and being hard on yourself in whatever situation you're in.
Just be tough on yourself. And just because that's what he was,
he was tough on himself. And so that's what I got from him.
And, but now I just think like, okay,
just do tweak everything up and just get mentally imbalanced.
And especially when he passed away like almost two years ago, she just,
yeah, it was tough. It was tough, especially when the,
the relationship we had wasn't like, it was like on and off,
on and off. And when it was on,
it was like a lot of discretion and he just just hurts and then things happened
in your life and he just tried to process everything and give it a,
a certain spot.
But it's just hard sometimes and you just need somebody outside of your comfort
zone to talk about that. And yeah, that, that really,
that really worked and helped for me. So I'm, I'm very thankful for that.
And just, you know, I think I always,
how I approach things is everything in life happens for a reason,
whatever, positive or negative. And sometimes you,
you know,
what happens and why it happened and sometimes you probably know it after like a
few years and maybe you'll never know it. But in my, my opinion,
everything in life, positive or negative happens for a reason.
And it's just, yeah, it's on you.
Whether you does that or doesn't. If you decide that it does
that, it happens for a reason and you can find benefit in good or bad things,
then it does happen for a reason.
But you make that distinction that it's going to be for your benefit,
that it can help you in the long run. That's the difference between a person who
takes [inaudible],
things that happen, adversity in life,
and decides that the world is against them. Yeah. Oh, I'm old.
I can't catch a break. The world's fucking me over.
Those people wind up becoming losers versus someone who says, you know what?
We're going to be fine. This is going to make me better.
It's gonna make me stronger. This is gonna make me understand I'm, I'm,
even though I'm more vulnerable right now,
this is going to make me understand myself better.
It's gonna ultimately make me better at everything I do. If you decide that,
then they do, then things do happen.
Exactly. And that's,
and that's one of the reasons I love watching your port podcast,
because that's what you bring.
And especially what I think for people that maybe sometimes struggle with
certain things or like you just explained in a situation where you think like,
fuck, what the fuck did I do to life?
That constantly ever been just backfires on me. It's,
I always think like you are responsible for the choices that you make in your
life. Nobody else. You're also
possible for how you accept or how you focus on your life.
Exactly how you think about things and how you, how you process it,
your response before.
Yeah. So, and those,
those are things like are so important to me and that's why I that and that's
what I mean with,
I try to surround myself with people that boost my flame
and just look at my phone and it's like go through it. Like who did I text?
Or who did I call? Like, you know, those people need to boost flame.
They need to be important in one way or the other doesn't.
It doesn't mean that they have to to to be important in business or in work or
it can be in every, in love or in family or whatever.
It needs to be important in some kind of way.
I just need to have positivity around me because I've seen so many negative
things from my family side that it's like it doesn't work.
Drains you. It drains you. And I believe like it's like Karma.
If you, you're negative,
you will attract more negative things.
If you're positive or positive, things will come your way.
I'm 100%. I believe that as well.
Do you um, have uh,
a visualization plan when you go into a fight,
like say like this rematch with bought her heart, do you,
you're going to sit down and visualize certain scenarios.
Do you train your,
your thought process to go over scenarios or to have a game plan in your mind,
the way execute the fight the way you would like to imagine it?
Of course, of course. Think every fighter does. And
this is something you set aside,
like do you meditate and set aside time to do that or do you just,
no, it's just, just happens. You're just doing it all the time.
You're in the car, you know? Right. Just, yeah,
just have them when you're under threat Neil, whatever, it just,
it just happens when you, you think about what's gonna,
what's going to happen in the upcoming months.
You just know that, okay this is going to be next level. Okay,
but how are we going to approach this fight? What is going to happen?
What might happen if he does this? I do that. Okay.
But this could happen and that could happen.
And in my mind before going into the fight,
I find it already like a thousand times or maybe even more,
cause you're thinking about this,
this person and this fight for so long and for like three or four months.
That's, that's a long time. So that happens. And
what I always feel like,
what's fun to people to realize is that my confidence level during a period of
like three, four months into a fight goes like up and down,
up and down. How has that past, you aren't at fucking best of what you do. Yes.
Mechanism in the,
in training and in camp and how does does it ass, I don't know.
But that is what happens. I think that happens to everybody.
So you just accept the process. You just accept the process. But it's such,
it's such a fucking frustrating process that when you're, when you're here,
just got to get back up there again.
But you know that it's part of the process because I've been doing this my whole
life, so I know it's part of the, but still it's frustrating. So,
and that's what, for example,
[inaudible] a mental coach and a psychologist can help you with to cope with
that at that moment so that you don't stay here in June,
do climb back up again. But it's, it's, and then you say, well,
but where does that come from? Can come from anywhere, you know,
from your body being tired. Like, hey,
why can't I cope with this training? Or why is this training getting to me?
Or during sparring,
why did I get get hit five times with the right hand and then block or react or
whatever. So it can come from anywhere.
And then the monotony of training as well, right? Yeah, yeah,
yeah. So now this fight that's going to be happening in December, December 21st,
how can people get it? Can, is it going to be available on a,
is it on UFC fight pass? Yeah, it's going to be UFC five pass
and
I believe it's on ESPN as well. Okay.
Zit ESPN two I think so too. But I'm not 100% sure. Well,
I'll find out and we'll make sure we tell everybody when,
when it's taking place. So, uh,
we'll make sure we get a bunch of people to watch out for, of course,
fucking very blunt. This is going to be kickboxing history. So it is,
it really is. Like you said, probably the biggest fight in kickboxing history.
Yeah. So it's, and then of course yet like back in the days we had so much,
so many great fights in it, the k one tournament and there was,
there was amazing. But this is just the, the one,
the biggest one on one fight and from this time, from this time, yeah.
And this era that everybody wants to see,
well I hope a million fucking people watching or more and I hope it really does
open up the door for bigger and bigger fights because I think that it's,
look glory's amazing.
You guys have so many incredibly talented fighters and so many high level
fights. I fucking love it man. I'm just such a huge fan.
I don't understand why it's not bigger in America. I know it's bigger in Europe,
but that's
yeah, for us the same thing. So we just hope that during the years, you know,
we just keep building it up, building it up and hope like, for example, with,
with Anthony, uh, open up more, opening up more gyms,
more great American kickboxers and American fighters will stand up and competed.
Well that would be amazing. Who knows? This might be it, man.
This one might be the one that changes the tide. Exactly. Well,
good luck to your brother and thank you very much. Really appreciate you.
Appreciate your time. I'll let everybody know. Your Instagram, your Twitter,
what does, how did, how did they get up? My Instagram and Twitter,
it's all the same. Just Rico Verhoeven. Oh, and spell it.
Spell it out for people so they just know how to spell Verhoeven.
So it's R, I, c o says Rico, and then v.
E. R. H. O. E. V. E. N. Alright, beautiful. That's it. Bye everybody.
Thanks guys. Please.